temps bonjour et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro de parlement hebdo
compagnie de michaël szames f bonjour
michael l'argent c'était la semaine de
rentrée parlementaire marquée bien sûr
par l'intervention française au mali un
débat sans vote a eu lieu mercredi à
l'assemblée et au sénat
tous les groupes parlementaires
soutiennent l'entrée en guerre décidée
par le président françois hollande
mais des voix s'élèvent pour s'inquiéter
de l'isolément de la france sur le
terrain mariage pour tous ce petit chat
eu cette semaine dans l'hémicycle avec
des députés de l'opposition qui scandent
référendum référendum de référendum il
n'en est pas question l'examen du texte
a eu lieu en commission des lois et le
texte arrive dans l'hémicycle le 29
janvier
enfin françois hollande a prononcé ses
voeux aux parlementaires et annoncer le
programme une réforme constitutionnelle
d'ici l'été notamment sur le statut
pénal du chef de l'état
il y aura bien si une loi sur le non
cumul des mandats ce sera pendant le
quinquennat
pas de date précise ce n'est pas le
moment sans doute de fâcher les
parlementaires et avec nous pour
commenter toute cette actualité bruno le
roux bonjour jours président du groupe
socialiste à l'assemblée nationale
député ps de seine-saint-denis alors un
petit peu comme l'exécutif on peut dire
que vous étiez il ya encore pendant ces
quelques mois en apprentissage de
l'exercice du pouvoir on va voir comment
vous vous en sortez en tout cas ce qu'en
pensent vos collègues députés en
écoutant plume je trouve que ça
c'est un symbole aussi un monde occulte
et c'est un bon président il pas facile
des adversaires politiques mais c'est
normal c'est autant se cantonne à un
adversaire autant qu'ils soient
valeureux est capable étant moi-même
président du groupe de la gauche
démocrate et républicaine
j'ai forcément affaire à lui assez
régulièrement on échange je trouve qui y
conduit son groupe d'une main ferme
vous me demandez de dire du bien de mon
président donc je vais vous en dire du
bien écouter bruno le roux est un homme
qui aime le débat qui
aime aussi le consensus donc il ne
tranche pas dans le vif il laisse les
uns et les autres débattre par les
prendre des initiatives ils nous
demandent d'ailleurs de le faire
débattent avec le roux car au moins
c'est toujours direct et on se fritent
régulièrement
c'est un parlementaire ayéri un
adversaire politique
mais il ne pas fondamentalement
antipathique vous avez attendu un bout
de leurs goûts françois slama qui a
interrogé à tous ses députés
c'est plutôt et le jeu alors une
question qu'est-ce qui lé plus simple
être le patron de d'un groupe dans la
majorité ou dans l'opposition et dans la
majorité
vraiment mais la question j'allais dire
plus simple parce que ça correspond à ce
que l'on veut faire
on ne s'engage pas en politique pour
être dans l'opposition si on s'en va
gérer quand même il faut l'accepter
d'être dans l'opposition moi je les
accepte et pendant dix ans il faut
assurer dix ans c'est long j'ai eu la
chance de commencer ma responsabilité de
parlementaire avec enel jospin avec jean
marc ayrault président groupe 5 ans dans
la majorité on apprend vite quand on est
cinq ans dans la majorité
et ensuite je peux vous le dire dix ans
dans l'opposition quand on est confronté
aux attentes de ses électeurs
il ya des gens qui espèrent en vous et à
qui l'on dit mais non là je m'oppose
mais je n'arrive pas à faire je n'arrive
pas à réaliser ce que j'aimerais dire
c'est quelque chose d'assez frustrant et
donc moi je suis heureux d'être
aujourd'hui dans la majorité
parce que quand on est élu c'est de vous
faire des choses ménages et du coup la
volonté gouvernementale avec les
velléités les volontés des députés qui
sont pas forcément les mêmes il faudrait
quand même il faut tout simplement que
chacun soit à sa place moi j'ai voulu
être président de groupe vous savez
parce que j'ai une relation client de la
république qui est une relation qui est
plus que politique puisque loyal je suis
au service du président de la république
depuis longtemps sans pour autant et
dans un rapport de soumission nous
discutons de tous depuis des années mais
je veux qu'il réussisse son quinquennat
et j'ai pensé très tôt que s'il gagnait
il fallait à la tête de la majorité à
l'assemblée nationale quelqu'un qui soit
capable non simplement de trouver les
accords avec lui d'être en loyauté
parfaite mais en même temps de vivre
aussi sa vie de faire vivre au groupe
une vie qui est une vie normale pour
peser sur les décisions pour exister
dans le débat politique gaza je le fais
en toute loyauté
et je le ferai surtout les débats j'ai
prévenu le gouvernement à mon arrivée ce
sera le soutien nous soutiendrons mais
avec participation hors de question de
ne pas avoir les débats hors de question
de ne rien dire si godillots pas du tout
le rouge d'un mot et vous êtes arrivé
dans recadrer certains depuis ces
quelques mois notamment peut-être on
pense aux jeunes députés qui ont envie
d'avancer et l aile gauche du parti
socialiste qui s'est fait entendre
largement mais je n'arrête pas c'est une
partie l'attendait il cherche le
consensus toujours mais bien entendu que
je cherche le consensus parce que moi je
ne suis pas celui qui navigue dans le
rapport de force permanent de ce point
de vue là j'ai beaucoup appris avec jean
marc ayrault
avec françois hollande mais ça ne
m'empêche pas de dire les choses et de
ne pas en faire de publicité
quand je suis avec un député dans mon
bureau pour lui dire ce que je pense
d'une initiative qu'il a prises ou une
position qui a été la sienne
je ne fais pas de communiqués de presse
derrière pour marquer un territoire ou
pour marquer une fermeté dont quand
annick lepetit dit il tranche pas
toujours dans le vif c'est pas vrai mais
dans le vif non mais je tranche toujours
voilà je pense qu'il n'y a pas besoin de
trancher automatiquement dans le vif
allez on va dérouler ensemble bruno le
roux la semaine c'est le principe de
cette émission et on va commencer
évidemment par la france en guerre au
mali forces aériennes et troupes au sol
la france a donc renforcé cette semaine
les combats aux côtés de l'armée
malienne pour stopper l'avancée des
islamistes
mardi jour de rentrée parlementaire les
députés de tous bords manifestent leur
soutien à l'offensive décrétée par
françois hollande
mais avec déjà les premières inquiétudes
sur l'isolément français jérémy hartmann
silence et recueillement dans
l'hémicycle pour cette première séance
de questions au gouvernement de l'année
l'hommage de la nation au pilote
d'hélicoptère tués au mali vendredi
premières victimes françaises de la
guerre débutée il ya cinq jours
une guerre contre le terrorisme
unanimement soutenue par la
représentation nationale sur les bancs
de la majorité comme sur ceux de
l'opposition je vous remercie
lorsque les soldats français sont au feu
l'unité nationale n'est pas une option
c'est une nécessité absolue est un
devoir pour tous un soutien des députés
qui conforte l'exécutif dans sa décision
d'intervenir sur place notre pays est
uni dans ce combat il est uni dans ce
combat contre les groupes terroristes et
ce combat est un combat aussi pour nos
valeurs et ce combat est un combat pour
les valeurs des nations unies
l'intervention de la france bénéficie en
effet du soutien de la communauté
internationale mais pour l'instant
l'armée française est seul sur le
terrain et les députés attendent plus
qu'un simple soutien moral de la
communauté internationale nous nous
sentons quand même très isolée nos
partenaires occidentaux et notamment
européens il faut que l'on renoue avec
ce qui était prévu au départ
c'est à dire qu'une force africaine
prenne le relais progressivement car la
crainte principale reste celle de
l'enlisement
combien de temps les forces françaises
doivent elles restées sur place pour
quels objectifs
les communistes font partie de ceux qui
s'interrogent l'intervention militaire
ne règle jamais durablement la question
il faut donc savoir quelle sera la
solution politique
demain dans l'hémicycle le chef du
gouvernement devra répondre à ces
questions
même si le débat prévu ne donnera pas
lieu à un vote des parlementaires
et justement mercredi lors de ce débat
sans vote au sénat et alès et à
l'assemblée nationale députés et
sénateurs ont réaffirmé leur soutien à
l'opération française mais avec des
inquiétudes de plus en plus affirmée
écouter jean françois copé qui
s'exprimait à l'assemblée nationale au
nom du groupe ump
je devais
monsieur le premier ministre résumer
d'un mot l'esprit qui nous anime
j'utiliserai ces mots soutien mais
vigilance union nationale mes
questionnements et il me semble que la
gauche de cette émission pourrait être
un peu plus respectueuse de ce qui
convient d'appeler aujourd'hui la
position d'union nationale qui est celle
que nous vous proposons monsieur le
premier ministre
parce que c'est l'intérêt supérieur de
notre pays qui est en jeu et que la
nation se mobilisent contre le
terrorisme le djihadisme la haine
ce sont les valeurs de la république et
c'est pour cela que nous sommes aux
côtés du président de la république et
du gouvernement je vous remercie vous
entendez les craintes roux ne leur ou
fallait-il s'engager seul dans ce combat
j'entends les craintes mais à la
question fallait-il s'engager seul
c'est la question en fin de compte fadli
qu'ils s'engagent et parce que si nous
n'étions pas intervenus au moment où il
y a eu l'appel à l'aide du président
malien
si nous avions attendu de réunir autour
d'une une conférence pour savoir si nous
y allions et avec qui alors et
djihadistes alors les terroristes
auraient pris mopti alors les
terroristes auraient pris le mali alors
les terroristes aurait marché sur bamako
des islamistes elle n'est pas nouvelle
on la connaît depuis longtemps sait
depuis longtemps menaces n'étaient pas
passés du nord au sud et d'ailleurs
depuis plusieurs mois nous menons aux
nations unies avec une première
proposition résolution la 20 71 avant la
fin 85e la résolution qui n'étaient pas
forcément très bonne c'est beau c'est
que personne ne voulait avancer
nous essayons surtout de faire en sorte
de mobiliser une communauté
internationale qui a mis le voile sur
cette question malienne et nous essayons
depuis plusieurs mois par un travail
diplomatique de faire en sorte que
chacun prenne ses responsabilités
l'europe d'ailleurs est intervenu sur la
formation de l'armée malienne elle veut
pas laisser le terrain avec vous écoutez
moi je prends les choses dans l'ordre
je dis d'abord que nous ne sommes pas
isolés dans le sens où nous avons le
soutien total de la communauté
internationale nous intervenons sur un
mandat des nations unies et je n'ai
entendu personne dans la communauté
internationale nous dire que nous
n'intervenions pas à bon escient
deuxième élément pour l'instant je pense
que ça va durer il n'y a pas de raison
que ce consensus 16
ensuite ont répondu à l'appel du peuple
malien si nous n'étions pas intervenus
il y aurait aujourd'hui
situation absolument terrible avec un
pays qui serait sous la coupe sous le
joug des terroristes et aujourd'hui nous
sommes dans le cadre de la résolution
20,85 de l'onu en charge non pas de
faire un conflit et de mener un conflit
qui n'a pas de fin de faciliter la
mettrons de la mise en place d'une force
qui s'appelle la misma qui est une force
africaine sur laquelle je souhaite que
nous soyons rejoints par d'autres pays
et notamment des pays européens pour
participer aux pays européens pour
qu'ils s'engagent avec vous sur le
terrain militaire je le fais depuis
plusieurs jours je dis aux pays
européens qu'il n'y a pas de séparation
des fonctions et que les ans ne peuvent
pas être dans l'humanitaire quand les
autres seraient dans le militaire que
les gens ne peuvent pas être dans la
fonction logistique comme les autres
seraient dans le développement et qu'il
faut que chacun participe à toutes les
étapes de l'intervention ou non le roux
si le conflit dure plus de quatre mois
le parlement sera saisi
la règle est ce que vous conditionner
votre soutien à l'intervention
injustement une aide européenne ou dans
le cadre de l'onu
entendons nous bien le soutien à
l'opération il est conditionné au
respect des objectifs de l'opération
ce n'est pas parce que nous serions seul
et ne saurions pas rejoint par d'autres
que je mettrai en doute la pertinence de
l'intervention française
j'espère d'abord et je souhaite je l' ai
demandé au gouvernement lors du débat
que nous n'attendions pas quatre mois
pour que l'assemblée souhaite associer
ce qui s'est passé en afghanistan ces
dernières années doit nous donner une
leçon
le parlement a petit à petit était
évincé de suivi de ce qui se passait
jusqu'à ce que nous nous questionnions à
bon escient d'ailleurs pour savoir si
les buts étaient toujours respecté bien
je souhaite je souhaite que ce soit
différent aujourd'hui sur cette
intervention ma vie que vous avez saisi
avant les quatre mois de conflit bien
sûr et j'ai demandé d'ailleurs au
premier
oui j'ai demandé au premier ministre
qu'il puisse y avoir toutes les semaines
ça va se mettre en place à partir de la
semaine prochaine une réunion soit de la
commission des affaires étrangères soit
que la commission de la défense avec les
ministres concernés pour que chaque
semaine nous puissions avoir un point
sur l'avancée du conflit et pour
vérifier le respect des buts qui ont été
fixées par la france dans le cadre de
cette résolution
ayant souvent l'auditionner chaque
semaine par les jolies filles ang
laurent fabius nous allons faire en
sorte que toutes les semaines il puisse
y avoir des auditions qu'il puisse y
avoir des ministres qui viennent devant
le parlement
une crainte également aussi que ça se
termine un petit peu comme ce qui s'est
passé en algérie avec la multiplication
des prises d'otages et nous sommes face
à des terroristes
j'ai souhaité mois les qualifiés dans le
discours que j'ai fait en soutien à la
politique du gouvernement
des terroristes c'est des gens qui
prennent les gens en otages ce sont des
gens qui a service des femmes qui
mutilent des enfants qui tue ceux qui
n'acceptent pas leur règle qui tunis
ceux qui n'acceptent pas ce qu'il leur
demande et donc ses craintes que ça se
multiplient finalement les répercussions
de cette guerre c'est ça pour la france
mais le terrorisme c'est le terrorisme
c'est quelque chose qui est beaucoup
plus difficile peut être même
militairement à affronter que l'armée
d'un pays que l'on veut combattre pour
les faire reculer
nous avons là quelque chose de très
divers qui peut se fondre ici dans la
population qui peut mener des attaques à
plusieurs centaines de kilomètres et
c'est bien pour ça qu'il nous faut
mobiliser nos forces sur le terrain
mais les services de renseignement la
coopération internationale entre les
pays qui aujourd'hui ont des services du
renseignement c'est tout cela que nous
mettons en place aujourd'hui pour
protéger les français
mais plus globalement pour protéger la
démocratie on va parler bien sûr du chef
de l'état qui a changé un petit peu de
ton beaucoup plus martial en tout cas
l'air beaucoup plus grave
écoutez françois hollande cette décision
que j'ai prise vendredi dernier était
nécessaire si ce choix n'avait pas été
fait la question ne serait plus de
savoir quand puisque il serait trop tard
le mali aurait été conquis entièrement
et les terroristes seraient aujourd'hui
en situation de force
le chef de l'état qui prend qui a
évidemment le cas
le tas de chef des armées qui prend le
costume de chef de guerre vous qui
connaissez bien françois hollande
il a réussi là à prendre ce nouveau
costume
c'est une décennie décision
exceptionnellement grave que d'engager
son pays et il faut bien entendu avoir
des convictions une analyse de la
situation nous force dégagé une force
ville avait les français de l'as fait
moi je n'avais pas de doute cela puisse
surprendre certains je savais je l'avais
dit depuis plusieurs mois bien avant le
rebond de certains mais quand on est
confronté à cette situation auquel le
pays n'avait pas été confrontée avant
j'ai entendu des analyses sur le thème
françois hollande est président de la
république pleinement il le devient moi
je n'avais aucun doute sur la force sur
la préparation qui était la sienne et
sur le fait que dans tous ces moments là
il saurait être à la hauteur de ce que
commande de la population à la situation
et ce que souhaitait je suis tellement
heureux et tout dans un mandat dans un
quinquennat le plus dur est toujours
devant nous et quand nous engagions
notre pays dans une guerre bien entendu
le plus dur son retour n'est évidemment
mais parce qu'il a travaillé parce qu'il
ya des soldats qui se battre et moi je
pense le premier jour de ce conflit
damien boiteux dans son hélicoptère de
façon héroïque pour survoler pour
s'approcher des terroristes qui a été
touché par une balle
c'est une décision qui est difficile à
prendre que celle de faire rentrer un
pays dans un conflit mais en même temps
c'est au chef des armées c'est au chef
de l'état que l'on demande de prendre
cette responsabilité je le dit françois
hollande l'a fait avec toute l'analyse
qui était nécessaire avec toute la
détermination qui était nécessaire ce
qui montre bien que quel que soit ce que
l'on peut entendre depuis quelques mois
il est sur toutes les dimensions il est
bien entendu totalement président de la
république dans toutes ses dimensions
avec toute la force qui doit être
nécessaires pour ce poste
allez on va passer maintenant au mardi
le mariage pour tous comme une mini
manif dans l'hémicycle après le succès
de la manifestation à des opposants au
mariage pour tous la droite réclame
toujours un référendum
alors on ce mardi le sujet anime la
question dès la séance pardon des
questions au gouvernement
alors que la commission des lois se
penche sur l'examen du texte
iwan cela après la marche de dimanche
dernier
une autre manifestation dans l'hémicycle
s'il vous plaît immédiatement synonyme
d' incidents de séance
assumer le débat ici infantile pour
l'opposition
pas question de passer à côté de ce coup
de pression sur la majorité il y a
quelques jours la garde des sceaux
qualifié le mariage pour tous de réforme
de civilisation bien au-delà donc du
mandat de député selon henri guaino
la majorité ne cesse de nous le répéter
cosy causer encore cause est toujours en
fera sombrer quel parlementaire
reçu un mandat du peuple pour faire une
réforme de la civilisation
aucun d'entre nous
autre revendication d'une partie de
l'opposition être reçu en tant que
parlementaires opposés au projet de
mariage pour tous par françois hollande
on ne manque pas y aller tout sur le
monde à ce qu'il reçoive quelques-uns
qui représente en tant que parlementaire
il a reçu des associations qui
représentent tous ceux qui sont pour le
mariage pour tous et pas beaucoup de
ceux qui sont contre le mariage campus
commission des affaires sociales
commission des lois une avalanche
d'amendements se profile l'opposition
voudrait faire durer les échanges
la majorité refuse de passer en force
s'il y a obstrué sion de la part de nos
collègues de l'ump et bien nous leur
répondrons nous avons prévu notre temps
les opposants au mariage pour tous
disposent encore d'une quinzaine de
jours pour tenter d' amplifier leur
mobilisation
quinze jours avant le début de l'examen
du projet de loi dans l'hémicycle alors
on vous a vu batailler là au milieu du
chahut de l'opposition plus de 180
parlementaires à ce jour ont signé
l'appel au référendum qui a été lancé
par henri guaino donc vous résistez
toujours d'abord la gare de l'est soit
très bien à expliquer pourquoi ils le
savent bien d'ailleurs ce débuté
pourquoi sur ce sujet là si cette
société il n'est pas possible
d'organiser un référendum
ensuite il y aurait pu y avoir un
référendum d'initiative populaire vous
savez on en parle depuis des années sauf
que c'est la précédente majorité qui
après l'avoir dean l'a pas mise en place
et il n'a pas fait voter les textes qui
permettait de l'organiser alors c'était
une idée du président de la république
et enfin c'est le président de la
république qui peut convoquer un
référendum
il l'a dit il ne le convoquera pas parce
que ce n'est pas possible d'abord
constitutionnellement et ensuite parce
que il considère que c'est au parlement
de prendre ses responsabilités sur une
proposition qui a fait partie c'est
l'engagement 31 des 60 engagements qu'il
a pris devant les français et donc
maintenant et fermeté qu'il a voulu
démontrer françois hollande a une preuve
de fermeté c'est tout simplement qu' il
y a un programme qui était connue un
engagement qui est celui de puis
longtemps défendu et sur lequel il y à
un débat dans notre pays depuis des
années mais enfin nous ne sommes pas ici
dans un pays qui ferait avant tout le
reste
cette mesure nous sommes à la traîne
entendait pas la rue par rapport aux
nombre de manifestants mais nous
entendons la rue il ya toujours ce
courant en france qui refuse les grandes
avancées de société j'ai fait un petit
film il ya quelques jours que j'ai mis
en ligne j invite ceux qui nous
regardent aller le voir sur le site des
députés socialistes pour montrer que
pour le pacs c'était exactement la même
chose exactement les mêmes débats
exactement la même fait exactement la
même chose à l'assemblée au sénat que
pour le pacs est bien sûr nous allons
voter
il n'y aura pas le problème qu'il y
avait sur le pacs par manque de
mobilisation mais moi je le dis aux
députés de droite plutôt que de faire
quand il y a les caméras des incidents
de séance tel que demandé un référendum
plutôt que de demandes arif erdem qu'ils
savent qu'ils assument le débat moi je
vais vous le dire je ne les ai pas
trouvés très vaillant en commission je
ne les ai pas trouvés faisons la balle
il veillera des centaines d'amendements
nous peut-être qu'en fin janvier il y
aura des centaines d'amendements
est-ce que vous garantissez à ses
députés de l'opposition qu'ils auront
leur temps de parole qu'il n'y aura pas
tant programmée et que le débat qu'il
réclamera au moins lieu dans l'hémicycle
leur garantit que nous n'utiliserons pas
ce qu'ils ont mis en place dans le
règlement de l'assemblée pour faire en
sorte que nous ne puissions pas débattre
quand nous étions dans l'opposition
car enfin je le rappelle c'est ce qu'ils
nous demandent le débat aujourd'hui
qu'ils ont mis en place un nouveau
règlement de l'assemblée
son appel le temps programmé qui est que
l'on met à sa vie liés et que l'on
empêche l'opposition un certain moment
de parler et bien moi je leur garantis
le débat parce que je le disais il y à
un angle deux ans la place du débat
c'est à l'assemblée donc nous ne
limiterons pas et donc je leur faire
l'appel
l'arrêté demandé un référendum prenez
vos responsabilités
débattez et pour le reste que monsieur
guaino ne se plaignent pas qu'il y ait
une majorité que cette majorité soit
capable du goût au bout du compte
d'imposer ce qui est sa vue et son
programme
lui qui pendant cinq ans a été sourd à
toutes les manifestations
quand il était conseiller du président
de la république venir nous faire
aujourd'hui quelque chose sur
l'illégitimité du parlement ou sur le
fait qu'il y aurait une majorité mais
cette majorité ne serait pas légitime
c'est quand même cocasse la pma la
procréation médicalement assistée
vous aviez vous même insisté pour que l
fasse partie du texte du mariage pour
tous finalement on connaît la suite été
retiré
est-ce que
avec le recul vous vous reconnaissez que
c'était une erreur stratégique
pas du tout pas du tout c'est ce qui a
permis d'ailleurs qu'un second texte
soit annoncée moi j'y tiens à l'arrière
utilisation de position aussi le mot
mise sur l'opposition elle se faisait
qu'il y ait la pma ou qu'il n'y ait pas
la paix m
je n'ai pas vu beaucoup de camps parts
de pancarte dans la manifestation contre
la paix m
j'en ai vus contre le mariage contre
l'adoption et il y aurait juste avant ça
a été retiré mais ce n'était pas ce n'a
pas été retirée ça a été retirée du
texte nous avons annoncé que j'attaque
le mettre dans un texte qui va la
garantie du premier ministre que la
question de la pma serait dans le texte
déposé au mois de mars
et c'est à cette unique condition que
j'ai accepté de retirer du texte mariage
parce qu'il me semblait que le texte dit
sur la famille était un meilleur texte
juridiquement pour que cela prenne place
et donc c'est à cette unique condition
que j'ai accepté de différer de deux
mois cette question de la paix m
on ne nous parlait de l'opposition on va
encore reparler un tout petit peu cette
semaine l'ump à son nouvel organigramme
la version 2013 une nouvelle équipe
s'installe avec les fillonnistes les
copistes une union mais pour combien de
temps je lui 1 ils sont arrivés chacun
de leur côté copéiste puis filoni et
quelques minutes plus tard c'est l'heure
sur scène du grand rassemblement la
famille ump tout sourire deux mois après
une crise sans précédent
un seul visage et pas des moindres ne
manquait pourtant sur la photo celui de
françois fillon prix selon son entourage
par un engagement personnel de longue
date mais je crois que nous avons les
uns et les autres parfaitement compris
que ce que nous avons vécu ensemble ces
dernières semaines et le spectacle que
tout cela a donné devant les français
commandent maintenant un esprit de
rassemblement peut-être fini donc le
rhume groupes dissidents à l'assemblée
et bonjour le nouvel organigramme avec
comme règle le binôme à chaque échelon 1
copéiste et un filloniste travailleront
ensemble
ainsi laurent wauquiez valérie pécresse
intègre la direction du parti aux côtés
de luc chatel et michèle tabarot
vous l'avez vu tout à l'heure tout le
monde est ensemble tout le monde est
rassemblé certains même se sont touchés
donc ça veut dire que tout va bien
moi je ne m'impose pas d'aimer les gens
qui sont dans le même parti que moi et
je ne leur demande pas de mai mais parce
que c'est trop on n'est pas on n'a pas
désigné le tout ce vaccin jean françois
copé et françois fillon coprésident de
la commission d'investiture du parti en
vue des municipales de mars 2014
ils devront également la commission
chargée de réécrire les statuts de l'ump
la nouvelle équipe devra faire
fonctionner le mouvement jusqu'au
nouveau vote les adhérents en septembre
haroun alors il ya donc la dissolution
du rmp à l'assemblée nationale le groupe
monté par les fillonnistes c'est mieux
comme cela
en tout cas ça va figurer dans le
guiness book des records puisque jamais
il n'y a eu dans une démocratie je crois
en tout cas dans la démocratie française
un groupe qui si peu de temps
apparaissent dans une assemblée et
disparaissent ensuite ça montre bien
qu'on s'est servi à des fins partisanes
du règlement de l'assemblée nationale je
l'avais dit je le regrette parce que
cela a entraîné une confusion cela
entraîné beaucoup de problèmes dans le
fonctionnement de l'assemblée
mais je suis heureux aujourd'hui que le
grand parti de l'opposition on trouve
une capacité à s'unir a besoin de
paroles finalement un groupe pas moins
une question ne porte pas le temps de
parole en moi c'est une question de
confusion quand il y a deux groupes dont
on ne voit rien si ce n'est des
problèmes de personne qui puisse les
séparer je pense que ce n'est pas une
bonne image de la vie publique de notre
pays
ils vont être bientôt de nouveau en
campagne puisque l'élection du président
de l'ump c'est pour septembre prochain
est ce que réellement ça va être un
parti d'opposition et où ils vont être
en opposition interne fait tellement
longtemps ça fait tellement longtemps
qu'ils montrent que leur préoccupation
essentielle n'est pas l'avis des
français que s'ils peuvent encore
continuer plusieurs mois comme cela bon
va passer au mercredi françois hollande
évoque le non cumul des mandats mais sur
la pointe des pieds
en ce mercredi françois hollande
présente ses voeux aux parlementaires
très attendu sur le thème qui fâche le
non cumul des mandats le président
confirme qu'il y aura bien un projet de
loi qui concernera tous les
parlementaires mais il ne donne pas de
date
prudence est un sujet de jérôme rats
pied ferme et déterminée françois
hollande réaffirme sa volonté de mettre
fin au cumul des mandats pour les
parlementaires
j'ai donc demandé au premier ministre de
préparer un projet de loi pour en
terminer avec le cumul entre un mandat
national et un mandat exécutif local
cette règle concernera l'ensemble des
parlementaires
elle s'appliquera quelle que soit la
taille de la collectivité locale
concernée
l'ensemble des parlementaires c'est à
dire pas d'exception pour les sénateurs
qui sont les plus réticents
y compris dans la majorité le président
du groupe socialiste françois rebsamen
ne s'est d'ailleurs pas déplacés une
absence remarquée chez les défenseurs du
texte
c'est vrai que comme on savait qu'elle
présent la république allait intervenir
s'arrêter sont des mandats bien certains
s'étaient préparés mais c'est la vérité
du présent la république
et comme souvent il paraît qu'on nous
dit ah mais les écologistes et pas
toujours d'accord qu de présent la
république ça me permet de réaffirmer ce
jour après les voeux du président la
république notre soutien total pour la
rénovation
de la vie publique pour trouver des
opposants il fallait donc s'adressait à
l'ump pour qui cette future loi est une
absurdité
on ira vers une assemblée qui sera une
assemblée d'apparatchiks déconnectés du
terrain et qui seront des gens qui
seront finalement représentatif des
partis politiques mais pas de la réalité
du terrain
les débats promettent donc d'être animé
en contrepartie le président de la
république a affirmé qu'un texte sur le
statut de l'élu serait proposé l'idée
c'est que ce texte soit d'abord élaboré
après une période de concertation et ont
pris en parlant de la question du statut
de légumes avec une inscription au
parlement à 10 ans dans les six sept
mois qui arrivent
un examen au parlement en 2013 mais
reste à savoir quand la loi entrera en
vigueur
certains élus espèrent sa mise en place
pour les municipales de 2014
sans trop s'avancer françois hollande
promet simplement qu'elle sera effective
avant la fin de son quinquennat
donc bon le faux est un peu artistique
on ne connaît pas vraiment la date est
ce que réellement ce non-cumul
s'appliquera dès les élections locales
de 2014
je peux vous dire moi la volonté du
président de la république j'en ai
discuté avec lui c'est que cette réforme
sur le non cumul soit votée rapidement
et qu'elle puisse s'appliquer le plus
vite possible c'est-à-dire dès les
élections de 2014 et 2015 mais avec un
projet de loi comme le dit le ministre
dans le premier semestre de jeu pense
que le premier ministre va faire des
consultations là il va nous proposer
très vite un projet de loi pour que nous
puissions bien entendu en débattre avant
le renouvellement de 2014 les élections
municipales le mettre en application
mais pour cela il faut que je trouve une
majorité un peu plus large puisqu'il ya
nécessité à réviser la constitution et
donc chacun devra prendre ses
responsabilités l'opposition
l'opposition à l'ue dei lui donner
démocrate a d'abord je pense que c'est
une greffe forme qui va permettre qui
est une pierre angulaire de la
rénovation de notre vie publique et
qu'aujourd'hui c'est souhaité par les
français cette rénovation très profonde
et le non cumul et donc j'appelle tous
les parlementaires à s'engager
résolument dans cette voie et je le dis
si jamais nous étions bloqués par un
absence de soutien une absence de
soutien de l'opposition
c'est peut-être pourquoi il faut une
réforme constitutionnelle c'est pour que
des suppléants ensuite remplacé les
députés à l'assemblée nationale s'il
choisissait en 2014 ou en 2015 leur
mandat local
si nous ne pouvions pas faire cela alors
la réforme s'appliquerait avec un peu de
retard mais en tout état de cause elle
s'appliquera avant la fin du quinquennat
de françois hollande
alors ça c'est pour les députés mais
qu'est ce que vous faites des sénateurs
très nombreux des sénateurs socialistes
qui dit cette loi nous on n'en veut pas
d'abord je les appelle à respecter le
programme qu'ils ont défendues dans la
campagne présidentielle qui quand même
faisait de cette proposition élément
important de respecter la décision de
leur parti de ne pas être dans une
mauvaise explication on peut très bien
avoir un ancrage local on peut très bien
être en discussion avec les français
sans pour autant détenir un mandat local
être député ou être sénateur ce n'est
pas être coupé de la réalité et on a des
terrains on a des départements on a des
circonscriptions et donc je leur dis en
tout état de cause que ce serait mieux
que nous cheminons ensemble puisque de
toute façon au bout c'est l'assemblée
nationale qui aura le dernier mot je
préférerais à votre commun dans la
réforme constitutionnelle non dans les
3a guerre la réforme constitutionnelle
bien entendu mais la réforme
constitutionnelle qui permettrait aux
suppléants de remplacer les députés à
l'assemblée nationale j'espère bien que
les sénateurs qui n'ont aucun intérêt
dans cette affaire ne s'opposeront pas
et vous vous discutez un petit peu avec
françois rebsamen qui est votre mot love
et je n'arrête pas au cdh a conduit
foncièrement hostile nous avons les
meilleures relations et françois
rebsamen il sait bien que le cumul des
mandats et qu'une réforme inéluctable
souhaité par les français il est face à
un groupe qui comme beaucoup de deux
sénateurs défend aujourd'hui notre
position et moi je les appelle à nous
rejoindre et à faire en sorte que nous
cheminons ensemble at il rappelé est
quand même que c'était un voeu de
martine aubry
la réforme du non cumul des mandats
françois hollande il était cumulards il
était président du conseil général maire
de tulle n'était pas forcément d'accord
avec cette proposition
il l'a voté il l'a voté quand martine
aubry l'a proposé il l'a repris dans son
programme présidentiel et il pense que
c'est aujourd'hui parce que là l'élément
d'accord temps non parce que je pense
que c'est un élément important de la
rénovation tu peux être aussi cela peut
amener certains réfléchir parce que il
est soucieux des prises de position qui
ont été celles de son parti avant
l'élection présidentielle
alors
la prochaine réforme constitutionnelle
il sera également question de mesure
peut être beaucoup plus consensuelle les
anciens présidents ne siégeront plus au
conseil constitutionnel le statut pénal
du chef de l'état sera réformé la
suppression notamment de la cour de
justice de la république on va écouter à
ce propos françois hollande cette
concertation permettra parce que c'est
nécessaire de rechercher sur chacun de
ces points
la majorité requise pour mener à bien
cette révision c'est à dire la majorité
des 3 5e est dès lors que ce résultat
pourra être envisagée ce texte sera
soumis au vote du parlement réuni en
congrès d'ici l'été
jonah lomu sera peut-être plus facile de
réunir les trois cinquièmes sur ces
textes là que sur le non cumul des
mandats
concernant les députés jean marc ayrault
va en tout cas en on essayait de faire
la démonstration excellent faire la
démonstration dans les prochaines
semaines puisqu'il va consulter tous les
partis politiques et tous les groupes
politiques pour savoir si tous sont
prêts à s'engager sur ces réformes qui
sont encore à grand chose à faire dans
cette bataille en tout cas sur une
réforme constitutionnelle concernant le
statut pénal
non mais nous avons par exemple mais
j'espère en tout cas moi je le pense je
pense que nous devons clarifier le
statut pénal
je pense que nous devons faire en sorte
que les anciens présidents de la
république ne siège pas on voit bien ce
qui va se passer là a jugé en même temps
des choses qui concernent un ancien
président de la république qui est
membre du conseil constitutionnel
mais françois hollande prend quand même
la précaution de dire que ça ne
s'appliquera qu'à partir de lui et que
ce n'est pas rétroactif que cela n'est
pas une mauvaise manière faite ni à son
prédécesseur ni à ceux qui étaient là
avant et je pense que sur ces réformes
nous pouvons trouver une majorité large
vous parliez de promesses le droit de
vote des étrangers aux élections locales
c'était aussi une promesse là aussi il
vous faut la majorité des trois
cinquièmes pour pouvoir bien sûr la
métropole
j'ai demandé à jean marc ayrault s'ils
pouvaient ce qu'il a accepté dans les
discussions sur la réforme
constitutionnelle
demander à chacun des groupes politiques
s'il était prêt à s'engager dans cette
réforme soit en tant que groupe soit
laissé la liberté de vote à ses membres
de façon à ce que nous puissions juger
s'il y a une majorité possible ou pas
aujourd'hui les déclarations de la
droite montre
sonorités possible dans la majorité la
droite a montré ces dernières semaines
que malgré un certain nombre de propos
qui avaient été tenues toutes ces
dernières années elles étaient sur une
position qui était d'empêcher la
réalisation de cette réforme et je le
regrette
vous envisagez quand même de faire
passer ce droit de vote des étrangers
dans le congrès qui seraient réunies
avant l'été s'il y avait une majorité
vous semble éventuellement envisageable
s'il ya une majorité et bien entendu
aussi bien une majorité je souhaite que
cela soit adoptée le plus vite possible
donc c'est un contrat que vous allez
essayer de faire passer beaucoup de
choses quand même oui et nous pourrons
faire passer d'éléments de
restructuration de notre vie publique de
notre constitution que sur la base d'un
consensus large et c'est pour cela qu'il
faut ce travail de consultation qui est
mise en oeuvre par jean marc ayrault le
premier ministre aujourd'hui
allez on va passer au jeudi séminaire
sur l'emploi à matignon sur fond de
crise chez renault alors évidemment
l'annoncé a fait l'effet d'un coup de
massue
renault annonce 7500 suppressions de
postes d'ici 2016
le ministre arnaud montebourg se réjouit
qu'il n'y ait ni fermeture de site ni
licenciement
un point de vue que ne partagent pas les
syndicats rim benameur nouveau coup dur
pour l'automobile française
après peugeot c'est au tour de renault
d'annoncer des suppressions de postes
15% des effectifs en moins soit 7500
emplois supprimés d'ici à 2016 mais pas
de fermeture d'usiné ni de licenciements
secs
la marque au losange ne remplacera pas
les départs à la retraite et incitera au
départ anticipé l'état actionnaire à
plus de 15% se félicite de la méthode
choisie
les lignes rouges que le gouvernement a
fixé premièrement c'est pas de plan
social pas de licenciements cette
première ligne roule et respecté
deuxièmes lignes rouges pas de
fermetures d'usinés
pas de fermeture de site deuxième ligne
rouge est respectée depuis novembre
direction et syndicats de renault
négocie des accords de compétitivité
carlos ghosn exige des salariés des
sacrifices alignement du temps de
travail et mobilités forcées
en échange il promet qu'en cas d'accord
pas de fermeture de site un chantage
pour les syndicats qui se sentent
abandonnés
c'est vrai que de demander à des
personnes de partir à plus d'une heure
et demie voire trois heures de leur
domicile pour aller travailler c'est
vrai que beaucoup de personnes qui ont
peur de cette chose à le gouvernement
avait dit qu'il allait se battre contre
le chômage c'est des menteurs
si son complice ils laissent faire un
groupe comme renault des débrayages sont
prévus sur les différents sites de
renault et une journée de mobilisation
aura lieu mercredi prochain
alors on a connu arnaud montebourg
beaucoup plus offensif sur d'autres
dossiers ce qui n'est pas un peu
optimiste il se réjouit finalement qui
qu'il n'y ait pas de licenciements secs
ne se réjouit absolument pas du tout il
a donné les deux lignes rouges du
gouvernement mais enfin et qu il utile
de rappeler son que les choses la
paresse de troc
nous sommes dans une crise économique
crise mondiale et que cette crise et
renforcer sur le secteur de l'automobile
il suffit de voir les chiffres sur
l'année 2012 devoir pour paroles je suis
des ventes pour voir kylie a aujourd'hui
dans sa qu'industrie non simplement une
baisse de la demande mais en même temps
des entreprises notamment les
entreprises françaises qui parlait choix
qu'elles ont fait ces dernières années
c'est peut-être un peu plus visible pour
peugeot citroën pour renault mais
souffre encore plus que dans
l'entreprise et donc quand on dit qu'il
y a dans cette période de crise une
restructuration qui préserve les sites
qu'ils ont dans notre pays et qui dans
le même temps l'entraînent aucune
suppression d'emploi je pense qu'on ne
peut pas se réjouir que dans le même
temps on peut dire que les lignes rouges
n'ont pas été franchis et qu'aujourd'hui
ce qu'il convient de faire en sorte que
dès la sortie de crise ces entreprises
puissent retrouver de la capacité à
conquérir de nouveaux marchés à sortir
de nouveaux modèles et à redévelopper
l'emploi carlos ghosn le patron de
renault dit que l'avenir tel qu'il est
aujourd'hui de la marque est en péril
très clairement il dit qu'il ya une
crise demande ce plan compétitivité
oui et dans le même temps nous voulons
discuter avec lui pour faire en sorte
que ce plan compétitivité qui est normal
nous parlons de la compétitivité des
entreprises ce n'est pas pour la refuser
à renault mais il faut regarder ce qu'il
est en train de faire le point dans nos
spas et chantage c'est en même temps ils
essayent de montrer l'adaptation qui
doit être celle de son entreprise et
nous nous sommes dans une situation de
lui dire que le
l'emploi n'est pas la variable
d'ajustement et que quelquefois il ne
faut pas derrière ces questions d'emploi
cacher des questions qui ont été les
questions de stratégie et peut-être des
interrogations qui lie à avoir sur la
stratégie de l'entreprise même une
semaine à peine après avoir signé
l'accord le fameux accord historique
selon françois hollande entre le
patronat et le syndicat
là il se trouve entachée c'est un coup
de canif finalement mais si la montre
bien que cet accord il est là parce que
la situation est difficile
nous n'aurions pas eu besoin d'un accord
avec les partenaires étaient d'accord et
pourquoi il n'est pas respecté les
discussions préalables avec les accords
entre le syndicat et et d'entre eux
attendait là nous sommes dans un accord
qui a été discuté dans l'entreprise et
dans une décision d'entreprise qui a été
faite bien avant l'accord avec les
partenaires sociaux
et donc il ne faut pas prendre cet
exemple pour essayer d'entacher un
accord qui est un compromis historique
tel qu'il n'y en a jamais eu dans notre
pays et qui va permettre plus de
sécurité par les salles d'ailleurs à
minima accord a minima
moi j'ai vu que tous les syndicats sont
restés autour de la table jusqu'au bout
et j'ai vu qu'il y avait les sécurité
pour les salariés comme on en a jamais
mis en place dans une autre période même
quand il n'y avait pas la crise en
matière de santé en matière de formation
en matière de droits au chômage et donc
ce qu'un bon accord qu'il a pour les
salariés un accord qui permet aux
entreprises dans des périodes difficiles
de mieux s'adapter dans cet accord il
serait présenté à l'assemblée en avril
en procédure d'urgence
est-ce qu'il sera transposée en projet
de loi quasiment dans les mêmes termes
mais pas quasiment dans les mêmes termes
bien entendu dire une transposition
jeudi cas mais il y aura peut-être les
amendements mais ce que je dis c'est que
par exemple
non il y aura des volontés peut-être de
le faire mais enfin que quelle
crédibilité
aurions nous à avoir souhaité une
conférence sociale à vouloir un accord à
dire que nous respecterions cet accord
si au bout du compte nous étions dans
une transposition qui ne respectent pas
la discussion qui a eu lieu et donc la
démocratie sociale elle ne se substitue
pas à la démocratie politique mais il
doit y avoir une crédibilité une
concordance quand on dit les et qu'ils
me paient des députés godillots mais
nous sommes pas des godillots
quand nous mettons et quand nous
respectons les partenaires sociaux c'est
une façon de faire de la politique qui
est correspond à une démocratie plutôt
évolué pourquoi toujours être dans le
rapport de force
pourquoi penser que dans une période de
crise le patron
les syndicats ne sont pas en situation
de nous dire la façon dont il pense
qu'il faudrait avancer
pourquoi n'aurions nous pas à apprendre
des syndicats des partenaires sociaux
moi je ne suis pas dans la stratégie qui
était la stratégie de la tension
permanente que nous avions auparavant ni
dans une stratégie qui consiste à dire
que la majorité a toujours raison à
l'assemblée nationale parce qu'elle est
majoritaire sans trop de discussions
dont 103 discussion à l'assemblée il y
aura non sécurisés et la seule
discussion elle tiendra à bien vouloir
vérifier sur chaque point que l'objectif
qui est mise en avant c'est l'emploi
l'emploi l'emploi
à partir du moment où nous arriverons à
convaincre que tout ce qui est dans
l'accord facilite aujourd'hui le
maintien dans l'emploi sécurisé les
salariés et permet aux entreprises de
mieux s'adapter
c'est à dire de mieux favoriser l'emploi
et la lutte contre le chômage alors nous
respecterons bien entendu tout ce qui
est dans l'accord je vous propose de
terminer cette émission avec ce qu'on va
appeler le coup de gueule de la semaine
celui d'une sénatrice en plein débat sur
le nouveau mode d'élection des
conseillers départementaux
regardez cet échange et écouter les
changes dans l'hémicycle au sénat s'il
vous plaît mes chers collègues ne
faisons pas d'obsession sexuelle
collective est-ce que la parité est ce
que la parité doit se mesurer aux 50 50
et je pense que cette discrimination
positive on aurait pu sinon la m ne pas
la faire au moins la maintenir pour un
scrutin et six ans après on revient à
une situation plus normale
je crains que 8 ce matin soit un débat
qui soit terriblement agressif
j'irai voir pardon vous pouvez répéter
un petit peu plus fort ce que vous
vouliez dire monsieur le sénateur vous
venez de dire parce que des fois ne se
serait pas aux jeux vidéo vous venez de
dire à mon propos pendant que je parlais
de la parité c'est qui cette nana je
souhaite que ce soit bien inscrire votre
nom s'il vous plaît
monsieur sido je crois que vous avez
gagné peut-être ce matin la palme du
misogyne
bof de cette assemblée ne le roux c'est
là qu'on se dit que la parité cette puce
est très très loin d'être gagné
finalement elle est entendue et il ya
toujours les mêmes comportements et il y
a toujours des mêmes dans vous n'avez
pas besoin de dire qu'il s'agit de deux
sénateurs du groupe ump qui faisait ses
réformes et à chaque fois que nous avons
essayé de faire progresser la parité
d'abord c'était toujours la gauche
toujours toujours la gauche qu'il y
avait toujours cette même chose qui
était dit comme quoi ça ne servait pas à
grand chose que de toute façon la nature
hors frais les choses au fil du temps
que les compétences n'était peut-être
aussi pas là avec des remarques telles
qu'il y à là et nous nous voulons à tout
prix faire en sorte que sur tous les
modes de scrutin il puisse y avoir le
plus vite possible la parité l'égalité
hommes femmes dans la vie
professionnelle ça sera un projet de
najat vallaud belkacem dans les
prochaines semaines et nous ne lâcherons
rien sur cette question de l'égalité
hommes femmes
bon eh ben le combat continue c'est une
bonne chose un bruno le roux merci
d'avoir été avec nous dans cette
émission
quant à nous on se retrouve la scène